We just mentioned Blue Button,
which began in the VA in 2010,
and was adopted by ONC in 2012.
Their SNI work group expanded
the standard, added more structure,
and dealt with direct integration
to create Blue Button+.
This graphic from the Blue Button+ site,
shows how it can be used in conjunction
with direct, to move the data from the
providers, EMR, to the patients, PHR.
This one shows that Blue Button+ can
be used to bring data from multiple
providers, into one patient
manage technology, such as a PHR.
The data itself is in an XML document,
formatted according to CCDA.
You should recall that CCDA documents
are constructed from templates for
the document, its sections,
and the actually data entries.
Here's a list of some of the sections
of the Blue Button+ CCDA.
More recently,
the Blue Button+ rest API effort,
is offering a restful API approach
to using Blue Button+ for
both its traditional role, push, where
providers send the files to patients.
Or their designated PHR app,
as well as pull, where patients can in
effect subscribe and receive updates, as
new data comes into their providers EHR.